speaking of embarrassment and shame
a new poll confirms what should
obviously be the case
and yet in america when 60 million
people voted for donald trump
it would be wrong to assume that what
makes sense
will be most americans are embarrassed
however by the trump coronavirus
response
according to a new ssrs poll so not only
are we the laughing stock of the world
and the pity of the world
we are also embarrassed which is good we
should be
the right emotion is to be embarrassed
by what we've done
on this planet as far as coronavirus is
concerned so a few notes from this poll
disapproval of trump's handling of the
virus is up to 58 percent
great but how does 42 percent of the
country think trump did a good job on
the virus
that's a problem 8 in 10 americans are
angry about the response and 51
are very angry well people should be
angry but that's deceptive
because some people are angry because of
how bad the response has been
while some people are angry that they
have to wear masks so that one is a
little bit less clear
but then the headline seven in ten
americans are embarrassed by the
response
and we should be embarrassed because
it's been embarrassing and now there
are also two important indicators
in this poll about when things should
start to return to normal now
57 of americans say schools should not
open for in-person classes in the fall
some have already opened
but that's not a huge majority anyway
only 57
say keep schools closed in the fall for
in person do remote
for sports 49 of americans say
there should not be in-person sports 45
percent of americans say
there should be in-person sports these
are really depressing numbers
even with this polarized a country you
would think
you would hope that almost everyone
would realize
guys this is embarrassing obviously
we're not in a position to open schools
right now it's not about
never open them it's about let's just do
remote for one more semester and then
hopefully we'll have a vaccine and
better treatments and things can start
to normalize
in early 2021. no embarrassing
schools shouldn't yet open but that's
not what most people
or what nearly half of americans believe
now don't forget
when you look at these numbers we talked
about this yesterday on the show
somewhere between 40 and 50 of this
country doesn't even plan to get the
vaccine
which will make herd immunity impossible
in any kind of
short to medium term so the real
headlines here are reversed right
instead of wow 70 of americans
embarrassed by trump's coronavirus
response
the red alert is whoa 30 percent of
americans
aren't embarrassed by trump's
coronavirus response that's where the
focus
should be that's about 100 million
people
if you include you know out of the full
population which includes kids but
fine with adults it would be some
smaller number than that
20 percent of americans aren't angry
about trump's coronavirus response what
that's like 60 million people
oh wait trump got about 60 million votes
in 2016.
now if we go back to embarrassment for a
second
yeah we should be embarrassed about
trump's response
to coronavirus and i am but we should be
just as embarrassed
by the reactions and the behavior of a
huge portion of the country's people
i've said before when trump leaves we
still have 60 million trumpists to deal
with
we've seen protests against mass wearing
we've seen protests against social
distancing guidelines
we've seen people losing their minds in
costcos and walmarts about
liberty and freedom over wearing a mask
and
trying to stop the spread of a virus
conspiracy theories
about dr anthony fauci to the point
where he needs security and his
daughters need security bill gates
wants to microchip you it is
embarrassing
what trump has done but it's doubly
embarrassing when we look
not at trump himself but at his
administration's response
at the people around him and at our
fellow americans
at some point we're going to be past
this and we'll be able to do a
post-mortem
and we will need to include in our
analysis
not just an analysis of what trump did
and didn't do
not just an analysis of what the trump
administration didn't didn't do
but we're going to need to do an
analysis of the 60 million people
who voted once for this guy and are
going to vote for him a second time
hopefully it won't be enough to give him
another four years
and we have to contend with them for a
very long time and i've not
gotten any good answers to this i've now
talked about this for a couple of weeks
and the main point is if trump wins he's
going to do it with 65 66 67 million
voters
if trump loses he's going to lose with
60 to 63
million voters maybe even 64 million
voters even if he loses we have 60
something million trumpists in the
in this country they're on school boards
they are working in stores that you go
to
they are maybe your family they are
maybe your relatives your friends
whatever
what do we do about that because we as a
country
are not really going to be able to
advance until
we do something to weed out the ideology
that got 60 million plus people to vote
for trump not once but no doubt twice uh
or we have to figure out a way to make
progress
around them or despite them and i don't
know what the answer is
i'm always open to hearing ideas from
you
sunday is the 15th anniversary of the
david pakman show
august 23rd i still remember that first
show
it was pretty bad but to commemorate the
15th anniversary on sunday
we'll be doing a one-day huge membership
special the goal
being to bring in more new members
this month than ever before if you'd
like to be notified about this great
special it's really really good it's
actually it is by far the biggest
uh uh special we've run this year really
ever i would say
um and from the standpoint of dollars
okay
so all you need to do to be notified on
sunday is get on my newsletter my
mailing list you go to davidpakman.com
top right
of the page you will see a place to just
type in your email that's all you have
to do
and then sunday you will be notified
let's go to a quick break
make sure you're following me on twitter
at d
pacman i want to hear what you make
of the latest week in america post dnc
pre-rnc uh and we'll be back in just a
couple of minutes
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video